live at 8:00 p.m. tonight next a look at
the personal life of President John F
Kennedy from investigative reporter
Seymour Hersh he talks about his recent
book the dark side of Camelot and takes
audience questions it's about an hour in
ten minutes
I'm Karla Cohen I'm one of the owners of
politics and prose and I want to welcome
you here tonight to hear my good friend
Seymour Hersh psy has been a great
supporter of politics and prose over the
years and it's it's always a pleasure
when a book of his comes out it's a
there's a fair amount of publicity or
often and people are interested and we
can say that that's true this time as
well there's my partner Barbara Mead
standing in the back and so on behalf of
both of us I want to thank psy for his
for everything he's done for us over the
years and to say how glad I am that he's
here tonight with us you know Carl asked
me to come I come and I come period
I don't worry about it I just I'm just
here happy to be here great bookstore I
thought I'd just start by giving you a
little bedtime reading literally from a
memoir called Johnny we hardly know you
written by Kenny O'Donnell David powers
published in 1976 great bestseller it's
a it was a described as a warm intimate
portrait of JFK by the men who knew him
best and here's my favorite section he's
describing a Dave powers who was the
president's closest friend who's
describing a typical quiet evening at
home with the president and it says I'll
read you a couple of a graph or so Dave
was accustomed to being summoned for
night duty at the White House when
Jackie was absent he called himself
John's other wife the president hated to
be alone in the evening he was
understood the day would be available to
keep him company etc etcetera Dave stay
with him till he went to bed the nightly
routine was always the same the White
House kitchen staff would prepare dinner
broiled chicken or lamb chops left in a
second-floor apartment was called a
mansion by the Secret Service the the
main upstairs living quarter literally
apartments a good word for it nice
apartment on a hotplate appliance so
they could eat it late in the evening
without keeping any of the staff waiting
to serve them then they would watch
television to sit outside on the
Truman balcony or the president would
read a book or smoke a cigar while Dave
drank several bottles of Heinekens beer
they joke a little bit on 11 o'clock the
president would get undressed slipped
into the shortlink books brother
sleeping jacket that he wore in
preference to pajamas Dave would watch
him kneel beside his bed and say his
prayers then he would get in the bed and
say to David I'm not kidding
he would Denny would get in bed and say
to David and say to Dave goodnight pal
you please put out the light Dave would
put out the light leave Department say
goodnight to The Secret Service agent on
duty in the downstairs hall and drive
home to his own home the McClane sort of
like I guess you could call it the
Norman Rockwell version of life in the
White House but it is a history that was
totally a huge bestseller totally
accepted and so it's something you have
to deal with you know something I'm
dealing with all the time because this
perception this sort of he just didn't
have to do it this is a book that has
another interesting facet to it it's
it's not terribly long but it's pretty
long it's about 400 some odd pages in
paperback 500 pages in paperback and
it's about the presidency mostly and in
the index there's only one Hoover and
it's Herbert Hoover
there's no J Edgar Hoover in the index
the only other book I know like that is
a book called Kennedy by Theodore
Sorensen which is 800 pages long which
also has only Herbert Hoover in the
index I don't know what to make of that
but let me read you another document
just another sort of thing I'm when I'm
beginning to look look at this book
thing I'm thinking about I'm you know
I'm reading these books this is not a
book this is a document written by
Arthur Schlessinger the historian whose
books on Jackson and FDR he did a
three-volume series I remember reading
with great passion a long time ago when
as a kid after I was out of school when
of course everybody starts reading and
April the 10th 61 it's five days six
days before the Bay of Pigs invasion
it's a memo to the president the
political diplomatic and economic
problems were facing some of you might
remember your history Bay of Pigs was
the great defeat for the Kennedy
administration
and he's giving some advice and how the
Russians will exploit the situation and
this is how he's talking to his
president he said the first communist
effort will be to nail down the already
existing impression that such a landing
is sponsored the landing of Cuban exiles
on Cuba at the Bay of Pigs is sponsored
to combat the existing impression such a
landing is sponsored by the US no matter
how extensively Cuban the operation is
in fact in fact is in personnel and
equipment most of the world are friends
as well as foes will assume that it is
American in his conception he's talking
to a president and they both know of
something of course that is totally
American its conception the CIA is
operating it doing it it's not that the
Cubans don't want to go but it wouldn't
happen without our involvement so he's
talking and sort of I don't know I don't
know how to describe that language but
he goes on and he's talking about how
the Russians might exploit it and he
goes on to say it's a long memo ten
pages and he said maybe we should do a
per diversionary measure that might
offset Soviet propaganda after the
operation can we not affirm in some
striking way our support for progressive
governments in Latin America like
Venezuela can we not do something in
Africa or Asia that will counteract the
Soviet we're unregenerate imperialists
could something be bought before the
United Nations in the next 10 days which
permitted us to take a strong anti
imperialist position as we go on
invading the country Danny says the
following point 10 protection of the
president the character and repute of
President Kennedy constitute one of our
greatest national resources nothing
should be done to jeopardize this
invaluable asset when lies must be told
they should be told by subordinate
officials the next sentence is
underlined at no point should the
President PS to lend himself to the
cover operation that is the flimsy cover
that is an indigenous Cuban operation
without any outside help for this reason
right Schlessinger there seems to be
married in secretary Russ suggestion
that someone other than the president
make the final decision and do so in his
absence that is the final decision to
invade and do so in his absence -
someone whose head can later be placed
in the bloc if things go terribly wrong
well you really hear it so cleanly and
you really do hear it so cleanly you
know even in a document that wasn't
classified for 25 years not only do we
lie
but boss don't get near signing anything
of executing anything it's called
plausible denial so I know about this
document when I start I read the Johnny
we hardly knew you and I'll just tell
you briefly the genesis of this book
which is so mundane is to be sort of
staggering I have an editor his name is
Jim Silberman he used to be publisher of
Random House he's now little brown he's
the one who encouraged me Oh more than
20 years ago to start working on
Kissinger and about 10 years ago he
began whispering Kennedy Kennedy Kennedy
he's a wonderful man I'm always proud of
the fact that he he edited Philip Roth
which who to me is like manna anyway and
so I of course resisted I'm sure in part
because it was his idea and eventually I
started reading got into it and sort of
the heuristic approach if that's the
right word probably isn't the idea was
let's not worry about how he died that
is the assassination let's look at how
he lived and see what that might tell us
about how he he would die and I had
something going in I was a reporter at
The New York Times and in fact I many
you might remember did a lot of work on
the CIA and wrote a lot of the stories
that in more or less I'm not I'm not
over doing it under doing it but led to
the setting up of the church hearing
this the Senate Intelligence Committee
it was provoked by a series of articles
I wrote The Times New York Times and so
I knew that hearing very well and I I
watched it I moved away from Washington
so I was watching it just reading it and
what we had was this we had the Senate
Intelligence Committee doing a good job
uncovering this awful business of
assassinating Castro and other
assassinations true hielo
in the dr there was some some material
in nzm in vietnam and we had them say
well what's this about and they summoned
CIA officials the senior CIA officials
of the government Richard Helms and then
CIA director and other senior officials
Bissell the man who was the Operations
Director dick Bissell of the column
dickey-boy of the CIA and they some of
them and they
get him before the committees and they
shuffle around and they say well and the
senators say you know trumpeting I guess
maybe like Fred Thompson I don't know
trumping away and well who authorized it
well we thought we had authorization
they muddle and groan well of course the
Senators as I later learned in doing
this book and talking them all
understood that the president authorized
them but the CIA is out of business if
the head of the CIA Richard Helms says
that the Senate committee daddy sent me
the CI the president told me to do it
they're out of business and I've got to
tell you something it makes me creep
when I think about it it's a heinous
angel this is an agency that can conduct
any heinous operation on behalf of the
president United States with what they
call plausible deniability Arthur's
Arthur Schlessinger
was describing it we must lie if
somebody else has to sign it you can't
be near anything heinous and so the CIA
can be instructed by the president to
kill a foreign leader and the president
can rest assured that in case god forbid
nobody could foresee this in 1961 62 63
nobody could see a hearings in which the
Senate committee would be asking a
senior CIA official who told you to go
and how did you do it and there's
something so odious in this above and
beyond what I'm writing about what this
book is there's something per se odious
in an institution that exists to serve
the executive solely with total complete
deniability for the executive in case
anything goes wrong there's something
really profoundly wrong but we haven't
even gotten to that issue yet I mean in
talking about this book because it's
still we're still not not there yet in
thinking about it in any case so I knew
when I finally decided to do this book I
knew that I could cash in that story I
knew that I could get retired people in
the CIA to say look of course we took
the fall what else are we going to do
but of course they sent us my god I
didn't know how much I could get I
eventually was led one of the committee
met one of the senators who's now out of
the Senate sent me literally a FedEx
care package full of documents that had
been seen by the committee and that
never made day of light that really
moved it much closer in the Oval Office
I'll tell you right now the committee
so saw the committee also saw the two
ranking senators tersh was one of them
so the famous Hoover file official and
confidential file on Jack Kennedy the
one that's never been seen the light of
day I know that file was given to them
in 76 it existed it's gone we can't find
that I don't know where it is probably
shredded by the Senators after all there
were Democrats it was a democratic year
76 I can't imagine what happened in any
case what emerged from the hearings was
a muddled finding by this by the Senate
Intelligence Committee that nobody no
executive official was responsible they
couldn't fix it and there were a lot a
lot of talk publicly about rogue
elephants yes I'm sure the CIA is a
rogue elephant on the fringes when it
comes to being told to kill a foreign
leader particularly one an operation
they didn't really approve of eventually
eventually they got very tired of trying
to kill Castro they tried eight times
you know without doing it in any case so
I just pose all that as some stuff I
know knew I would cash in and what
happened next is I'm learning a lot
about the CIA and I'm learning a lot
though I'm learning a lot about ZM I'm
learning about a lot about Trujillo I
all vouchsafe to you that we don't know
nearly as much of all this stuff as we
do recently no and I'm learning a lot
about and that never made Dave light
that really moved it much closer than
the Oval Office I'll tell you right now
the committee also saw the committee
also saw the two ranking senators tersh
was one of them so the famous Hoover
File official and confidential file on
Jack Kennedy the one that's never been
seen the light of day I know that file
was given to them in 76 it existed it's
gone we can't find it I don't know where
it is
probably shredded by the Senators after
all they were Democrats it was a
democratic year 76 I can't imagine what
happened in any case what emerged from
the hearings was a muddled finding by
this by the Senate Intelligence
Committee that nobody no executive
official was responsible they couldn't
fix it and there were a lot a lot of
talk publicly about rogue elephants yes
I'm sure the CIA is a rogue elephant on
the fringes when it comes to being told
to kill a foreign leader particularly
one an operation they didn't really
approve of eventually eventually they
got very tired of trying to kill Castro
they tried eight times you know without
doing it in any case so I just posed all
that as some stuff I know knew I would
cash in and what happened next
I'm learning a lot about the CIA and I'm
learning a lot though I'm learning a lot
about ZM I'm learning about a lot about
Trujillo I'll I'll vouchsafe to you that
we don't know nearly as much of all this
stuff as we do Musolino and I'm learning
a lot about Castro and the obsession the
presidential session with Castro I'm
also really being troubled by there's no
question that before we took the White
House Jack Kennedy authorized something
called executive action a capability
only a capability but he asked senior
people of the CIA to set up a capability
execute foreign leaders it was a Kennedy
operation sought by the president before
he got in the office I can't I don't
have a videotape but I make an argument
for it
and I'm willing to take the brickbats
for it there's no question he wanted
this to happen I do have some notes and
Diaries that haven't been published that
suggests that very strongly do more than
suggest that just about say it and I've
done interviews with people and of
course it's anyway them to go on while
doing this work and being a little you
know looking at the the Missile Crisis
again in a different light in light of
what we were doing the Castro in terms
of we've always the Missile Crisis has
always been explained by Khrushchev's
irrationality Nikita Khrushchev put the
missiles in the Cuba as an act of
defiance to try and rectify the [ __ ]
cheek imbalance which by the way was
3,000 warheads for us 250 for him
there's no way he's going to rectify his
strategic imbalance by a few missiles in
Cuba as a lot of us knew but anyway
and it's different to say it's fun it's
sort of interesting to see a different
picture one in which Khrushchev is not
quite as irrational quite not quite the
tinhorn dictator that we thought at the
time but maybe moving largely not solely
but largely to protect an ally he saw
his coming under an immediate imminent
attack from us that is Castro okay so
it's a different history and at one
point I asked a guy one of the CIA guys
I said I was sort of what I was seeing
was what recklessness
I mean recklessness they were telling me
about opposition at the top of the CIA
to killing Castro and I was getting
documents that they were showing me
documents that were written in real time
expressing that opposition a little more
mutant thing we're saying it but in but
clearly saying what's the strategic
purpose of this
and as much as you could say to the
president and they were took being told
time and time again it's like some of
you saw that TV show sandy Smith the
Chicago reporter said up with Sam
Giancana when he had a problem he said
kill him kill him kill him well my
president was saying kill him kill him
kill him about Fidel Castro totally off
the top and so when I asked somebody
about the recklessness that's when a CIA
guy said to me he said Hersh you want to
understand John F Kennedy find his
agents Secret Service agents they'll
tell you what you need to know and many
you've been in government many you know
again the notion that for agents three
of whom spent their careers in the
Secret Service not only would see me not
only would talk to me but would go on
television says an awful lot about the
enormous I think disaffection maybe even
stronger words and that they had for the
further president they were going to
take a bullet for they both had an
admiration and a lot of contempt for him
too and and so that's what put me into
the next then then I knew I was in deep
trouble once they started talking to me
and we're willing to go on the record
play one story about one of them two of
the four were really very smart guys and
I had read a lot and both said to me
both of them said and when I talked to
him awful lot this is beginning in early
95 three years ago almost
they said they read Johnny we hardly
knew you they read Sorensen they read /
ginger and they kept on saying that
himself okay if that's the history the
American people want that's the way it
goes and one of them Tony Sherman a very
interesting guy first generation to go
to college very happy retired as a
special agent in charge of the Salt Lake
City office for the Secret Service you
know these guys these guys federal cops
who chase counterfeiters very dedicated
a small sort of elite group and they're
the elite assignment inside the Secret
Service is two years protecting the
president then you go back into the
field and a lot of these guys one in
Larry Newman worked undercover I can't
even tell you now some of the stuff he
did he's asked me not to some worked
undercover in some amazing stuff where
his life was on the line constantly
inside criminal operation so they are
interesting
so Sherman told me the following story
just as an example of where they were he
was a reader and he was caught up in the
Peloponnesian War great reader of
Carthage Cartagena if there's such a
word history he read a great you've just
caught up in that war and one day he
said in 62 they were in a trip to NATO
and the President had some business
meeting with many there was a chopper
taking off they were going someplace
from the airport near Rome was some
place in Rome
I shouldn't be I don't know exactly
where I don't remember and at the last
minute Tony's job was to jump on into
the doorway of the chopper a heavy ar-15
automatic machine gun I decide you know
in his lap and he jumped on and he sat
and sat in the in the opened open
doorway as the chopper took off and it
circled up above Rome and began to head
into the hills and McNamara was aboard
the Secretary of Defense at McGeorge
Bundy and the president and there were
four little seats there the president
has is as want a terribly nice man saw
Tony sitting there in the doorway you
know it was rather dangerous he wasn't
belted he was in a chopper flying moving
around he said Tony get out of there and
comes to stumps it with us and so Tony
there was in the chopper was a senior
official a senior inspector a boss for
the Secret Service he looked at the boss
and that's the way the chain of command
to the boss said okay so he went knee
buckled in next to him with george bundy
sitting across from the president of
mcnamara and Bundy was given a seminar
on on on the Hannibal crossing the Alps
and he had it wrong and so Tony's
thinking about what do I do
he's got it all wrong he's really
screwed it up and this is the president
so he said if I may mr. president
actually it was there and then they all
quickly I must say to Kennedy's credit
he said well tell us more and he said I
spent 30 minutes telling the president
what I knew and he said you know it's an
amazing thing so you have to understand
that's one side of it to come down to
the other side where he goes I'm willing
to go on television and saying what he
did was wrong and unpresidential I'll
just lay it out here it's a lot worse
than I even want to tell you it's bad
it's really bad it's bad as I write it
it's even worse and I'm not trying to
kid you around it's just a mess and so
there we are we have this reckless man
and privately we have a man who did what
he did and I am sitting there knowing
I'm in a firestorm and I did it the same
way I do everything else I want to do
want your questions because I know
there's been a lot of controversy about
it put it mildly
I don't like it but I anticipated it in
fact it was because of that I went to
ABC two years ago I knew that simple
words enough where maybe it's I just
knew words won't do it I thought maybe
the pictures would help and maybe it
will I don't know it's sort of early but
the thought was I getting it on
television was quite a feat - and
sometime you know in another life I'll
tell you about that it's not that easy
it's tough it's very tough in your face
television and so I claim this I say
there was a wonderful side the John F
Kennedy yes he went to the moon
yes he had vigor yes he was a leader yes
he has made people aspire to serve in
government he made government service
seem wonderful and he made the the
bureaucracy wonderful and which I think
very large it is and and he was bright
and he was witty and he was
self-defecating and he was very very
pretty and beautiful and he was somebody
who inspired us but my thesis simply is
that the dark side is much more dark
than we thought and maybe even more
important ultimately than the light and
in the end he was he had to get rid of
his the man in South Vietnam mr. Z M the
president of South Vietnam in the end
I'm not sure John F Kennedy believed in
the war any more than Robert McNamara
who wrote that amazing book in
retrospect in which he acknowledged he
did not think we could win the war and
yet sent boy after boy to die and
Vietnamese to die - John F Kennedy gave
us the first use I have to say this of
napalm against civilian targets in
Vietnam he gave us the first use of the
foley it's again food crops in Vietnam
he was the first president to authorize
massive relocation of civilians out of
their farms into what they called
fortified and strategic Hamlet's
basically holding pens for human beings
many of whom would immediately leave
they weren't protected in these large
concrete
forretress is / surrounded by barbed
wire and controlled by the South
Vietnamese government a day in the
Vietcong tonight we declared the areas
that they had left free-fire zones
eventually and would bomb and kill
anybody that moved in him and of course
many of the peasants went back there he
gave us that he also had a vice
president he couldn't stand I think very
was eager to get rid of him and I out of
this came up one moral that I have one
model for presidents I have some working
advice for American presidents which is
very simple don't die in office without
telling your vice president what the
hell you thinking about doing what your
policies are because it could lead to a
lot of trouble so I have a dist dark
view I'd love to talk to you about
there's you know we can go forever it's
I've talked 22 minutes 23 minutes longer
than I said let's go let's do questions
please sir I have to repeat him under
the rules of c-span yeah
well starting with a power isn't
Schlessinger I felt was an interesting
device and if nothing had been written
since then and it would give you a great
scope for what you've written but it
seems to me that while there's a lot of
Mythology nearly ears in recent years an
awful lot of the ground that you covered
is covered for it's just one book Neagle
a Moulton's nigel hamilton i don't have
a thousand pages reckless reckless use
is a very wonderful book but so I'd like
you to tell us what you really have to
add after books like that well first of
all I should say that Nigel handled his
book which yeah so let me repeat the
question that's absolutely the question
is that what's new you know so what's
new and is Nigel Hamilton wrote a book
in which he said a lot in fact Nigel
Hamilton's book ends in 1946 which is a
very important point to remember he was
going to do volume 2 and the abuse after
volume 1 was so great he went back to
London and I became obviously very
friendly with him he said he's an
unbelievably brilliant man I don't have
anybody's read as he's done did a
biography of monk of Field Marshal
Montgomery and he's way out there he's
gonna do neighbor now now he's running
an Institute for biography he's going to
do a multimedia biography Institute in
London a bunch of academic bunch
universities are funding him and the
government I think to some degree
but I must say about a week after my
book came out I called up Nigel and I
said okay buddy I finally understand why
you didn't do volume 2 who needs this
grief so that the answer is that Nigel
Hamilton I think did more to explain
John F Kennedy and I'm I'm sure I'm I
remember vividly going out of my way to
make sure that I don't suggest that I'm
writing anything new when it comes to
trying to dope him out I don't spend
much time in his early years I just try
and get some rough guy dia try and be
sympathetic to John F Kennedy because I
you know I think there were forces in
his life you know God knows I'm not
qualified even to think of the to being
at the comment but there were a lot of
forces in his family the most
interesting man in that family so the
answer to your question is you just want
about about what Nigel did and you're
probably wrong about what I did mean you
may not looked at what I did I find most
people that ask me those questions
haven't actually looked at what I did
because if you do look at what I did
what I'm getting now is I'm getting the
I'm getting everyday a lot of calls from
people that say hey boy you know I think
you know the sort of the adverse
publicity helps a lot because if it's a
reasonably coherent I can ride all week
on it you know my god you know this you
know there's no comma Falls anyway no
there were a lot of stories I'll give
you a typical example organized crime a
lot of rumors about it did a lot of work
on that found firsthand witnesses in one
case Tina Sinatra Frank Sinatra's
daughter who is in her 50s runs a
corporation for her father a large
corporation makes them you know I think
it's a hundred million dollar business
or more and has a production company
talked to her father
this is costarred we started as years
ago and enough talking to me at length
I'll absolutely concede quickly she's
second hand she's talked to her father
about what her father did to bridge the
gap between the Kennedy family and
organized crime but I'll take secondhand
sources like Tina Sinatra any day in the
week so I did make a conscious effort to
move some of the stories out of the myth
into into the reality a little bit at
least move them closer to being
demonstrable there's no videotape of Joe
Kennedy meeting with Sam Giancana to cut
a deal I will tell you that Joe Kennedy
is the most interesting Kennedy you know
he as some of you might remember I've
said this a lot of times he was in the
movie business in the late 30s and he
understood what we now call spin control
30 years ago and the genius of Joe
Kennedy is to take this beautiful child
this rather nondescript lackluster boy
who was in the Senate wasn't sure why he
was there he knew dad he wanted him to
be there and run him as a movie star and
win it he's the first guy to run
somebody it's a celebrity so I just
suggest you know you're right and wrong
about Nigel yes sir the dark side was
due to the free the free ride he got
from the press and is there any reason
to think that situation has changed how
much of the dark side was due to the
free ride Kennedy cut from the press
that is any reason to think it's been
changed its changed enormous Lee I'd say
for the better as much I'm nobody could
be as critical I have these days about
the press let me show you but having
said that you look at the difference
between 60 and 80 1960's in the 1980s
and 1960s whatever objection there was
to the war in Vietnam was based simply
on practical manners we weren't really
going to fight it right and the idea of
having the to fight stop communism
because if we didn't stop it there the
Chinese were going to come and etc etc
was just bought and sold by us although
there was a lot of scholarship available
saying quite the contrary
and so the press really in the early 60s
I think that the presses main complaint
is the war should be fought more more
efficiently by the 80s Ronald Reagan
could not sell a communist vet in
Central America to us he never could
sell it and the press was much more
skeptical about the the the the
imminence of the threat from the from in
Nicaragua and so that's a big
improvement I think also just in terms
of how we look at presidents after
Watergate things changed
you know we idealize presidents until
Watergate I mean we we never would
thought two things we thought about well
Johnson certainly we began to cut into
him pretty much too a lot and he quickly
bailed out but the bottom line is that I
think with Bill Clinton
what-you-see-is-what-you-get and we we
elected him knowing a great deal more
than we need to know about his character
I don't think I don't know where the
line is on private lives III as long as
it doesn't I don't care what anybody
does as long as it doesn't impinge on
their performance as president and I
don't care I don't care what Robert
Kennedy did or Ted Kennedy did or others
in that White House I care of what the
President did and in terms of its impact
on his
on his duties and his job and I don't
see any evidence that what Clinton does
in his private life has any impact on
his policies and I also think we know we
have much more informed consent I'm one
of those people that you know there was
a great review after James Algie of the
nation a key a jihadi a G a G EE I've
never knew how to pronounce it hearts
are geosoft G a G one when he reviewed a
movie he's to be a film critic for the
nation he reviewed a movie in 1939
called going my way with Bing Crosby and
and the Barry Fitz Bear Fitzgerald
remember that and his review had one
sentence I have to say in this movie I
want to start a be kind to God Club and
so I you know like today I would say I
want to start a be kind to Janet Reno
Club you know it seemed to me all she
did was make a decision based on the
merits and all of a sudden she's being
accused of being in some cabal sometimes
we you know we go too far yes Mary
McCrory writing in the post after the
ABC special on Kennedy concluded Kennedy
was a bad husband but a good president
would you comment well Mary McCrory you
know as she said she and I are dear
friends she also had a wonderful line he
said she said Jack Kennedy will outlive
sy Hersh comma not because he does not
because he deserves to you know it's
amazing line she somehow she's so she
really uses words like weapons you know
and I think he was a bad president
ultimately I think he left us with a bad
war I think he left us with a to get
back to his question about the press I
think it's very simple Kennedy's
enduring love affair was not with women
but with men not only Robert McNamara
not only Arthur Sylvester and not only
McGeorge Bundy but the press corps they
did want very much to be with him he was
where the action was Chuck Spaulding his
good friend who now lives in California
said to me when Jack Kennedy enter the
room he said the temperature went up 150
degrees he was not only just physically
attractive he had an immense presence
and you sort of knew the fun was where
he was at
you know you felt that and everybody
wanted to be with him and I think the
idea of doing what I'm doing I mean you
know you know look at the grief I'm
getting 35 years not later in trying to
get something I just think would have
been impossible for a journalist to do
something and negative it was such a
myth yes so go ahead your question was I
think bad president
I just think because Jack Jack Kennedy
it seems to me left us with one of the
things that came out Oliver Stone is one
of the things that came out of his view
of the world and I'm really ambivalent
about being compared to Oliver Stone
very him my somebody did in a review of
the television documentary and my the
guy who did it mark open houses this
wonderful filmmaker was flattered he
said hey that's seen on when he's good
he's really good
anyway um and when he's crazy he's
really crazy anyway yeah his view is
that Jack Kennedy would have ended the
war and let me tell you how I've you
think about that I found some a lot of
anecdotal evidence to support that
theory one of his good friends Charles
Bartlett was a wonderful man and that
Jack Kennedy had such a decent guy's a
friend says an awful lot there were
sides that Jack Kennedy that we can't
begin to fathom the word the Secret
Service used is faceted like a diamond
compartmentalize is another word this is
a man who could go through a mourning of
Dave powers of brooding about getting
rid of the girl let's there and then
brooding about some thread he had and
then go go to a meeting and perform
Bailey he just didn't seem to carry his
troubles with him as he went on from
from meeting the meeting and people talk
about his wonderful performance in the
Missile Crisis the tapes that have come
out he was on top of his game albeit I
still have reservations about how we got
there but for that week he was brilliant
and whatever his other problems were
there's a wonderful McNamara story about
an off-the-record McNamara story about
Jack Kennedy during the crisis that the
one of those nights when they were
having a the decision was Khrushchev had
sent two letters and what he going to
respond everybody knows his history if
it's most my many do they ended up but
he made a private and a public
recommendation and and one of them
called one of them called for getting
rid of them trading missiles that they
didn't wanna respond to publicly so they
responded to the first thing publicly
and took the deal any whatever they were
doing in the middle of all this tension
negotiation McNamara Bundy Russ for
president and Bobby occur
comes in a very beautiful young woman
from the Pentagon for with a message for
kafir McNamara has been staying in the
White House for days on end and the
president said to McNamara he said who's
that and he said oh it's an somebody
knew where we were so busy we're running
so many messages we she's from the
Commerce Department on loan and Jack
said well get her number Bob we may not
go to war tonight so he had this ability
you understand he was able to laugh at
himself his own obsessions he could look
outside himself and laugh at himself
about him and make fun of himself in a
ways that none of the other guy other
guys would dare do I mean so he he's
just per se interesting I mean god I
would have been I would have swooned
like anybody else anyway
on Vietnam the issue for me is this
Charlie Bartlett said to me that one
point in Charlie's memory is terrific
I've worked on he's just amazing after
all this was the president it's not hard
to remember what a president says even
probably took good notes afterwards
Kennedy once said to him I they hate us
they want to throw us out of there and I
want to get out of there but I can't do
it before the election he said I just
can't take the political heat he said
but I gotta I gotta get us out of there
was just awful and Bartlett as he said
to me was the first time as much as he'd
Meyer Jack Kennedy it was the first time
he ever really thought we should have
one 6-year term because the idea that
he's going to do this so I think there's
Kenny O'Donnell writes about a little
needless to say I'm rather skeptical of
anything I read in that book but maybe
he didn't have his pajamas on when he
talked to him and wasn't kneeling by the
bed and giving his prayers but Kenny
O'Donnell says that Jack said him I'm
going to get out and he's told the same
thing to Mansfield and he wanted to get
out he didn't think the war like as I
said earlier like Matt McNamara he did
not think we could win the war and you
have to understand if Johnson hadn't
done the madness Johnson did in Vietnam
taking 17,000 troops and building up to
550 and beginning the round-the-clock
bombing and this insanity we would we
wouldn't think what Kennedy did was so
mild what Jack Kennedy did he took 200
people and he built it up to 17,000 and
he expanded the rules
he had naked military men flying in you
know in mufti combat operations he he
put the CIA at work dramatically he
expanded covert operations in the north
north
a lot of Navy SEALs and a lot of he
began a program called I'll never forget
the word for eyes in four years wasn't
the precursor what became the Phoenix
program a good friend of mine worked in
it least I have the ace of spades and
they kill people cut out their eyeball
and leave the ace of spades beginning in
early 61-62 is part of a counter-terror
we call the counter-terror just like we
call nuclear hitting first counter force
you know from the target somebody first
anyway the point of all this is that so
Kennedy at the same time he's letting
the war go and he doesn't want American
troops there he's been against it
although all of his advisors playing to
john f kennedy's I told you John Kennedy
they love them so much they never gave
him his best they never gave him their
best everybody was too eager to please
they give him his best it's like Arthur
Schlessinger
writing about we you know don't even
sign the order mr. president we must
protect you all dear st. anyway so what
happens is as I won thesis I our guy I
don't know what the reality is I just
know they're the one possibilities Jack
Kennedy was as much of a hawk as we
think he was he sounded like and he
would have gone in and did with Lyndon
Johnson did expanded the war that's one
possibility I don't think so but what
happened is and this is what's new in
the book that really amazed me it turned
out in the summer and fall of 63 it was
there for the getting but none of us had
ever gone that way it's now I'm not
suggesting that this is the first time
anybody's ever found this stuff a lot of
new stuff is coming out and so V since
the collapse of communism and 89 Soviet
files have been coming out with
incredible regularity and it's almost
impossible for the press which isn't
doing a great job anyway to keep up with
it there's the Woodrow Wilson Center
here has a study of a historical study
bulletin that's been doing every year or
so they put out a huge volume of
translated Soviet documents in various
areas that's just brilliant that never
gets picked up by the press they're
doing a lot on one of the things that
that's come across is the sense that Ho
Chi Minh in the summer of 63 and ZM the
non-communist president of Vietnam began
talks secret talks to end the war as Ho
Chi Minh said to a communist official
and it's found in one of the documents
he said look I don't like Z M I've never
liked it they've been bitter political
enemies for 25 years he said but he's a
Vietnamese first and I can live with him
anything better than the Americans it
wasn't hard to see what we were going to
do
as we were doing it already by 63 the
destruction of that society was underway
the foliation napalm for let me give you
the kennedy argot fortified hamlet
strategic Hamlet's counterinsurgency was
all in place it was all there by 61-62
early 62 I sound like Noam Chomsky but
he's dead right on this and anyway I
should say NSAID but I sound like Noam
Chomsky and he's dead right on this so
what what Kennedy does kennedy knows
this he's very concerned about this and
I and there's a lot of I'm not just
quoting casually in the book I quote Tom
the former head of the State State
Department intelligence I just got a
letter from him today Tom Hughes is it
Tom he was he was at the Carnegie
Institute for years Tom Hughes told me I
remember I had to track him down in Asia
somewhere he said yes we all knew it we
actually some of us thought it was a
great idea what awaited in the war just
let him kick us out they were going to
kick us out they were going to get
together with the South North and South
we're going to begin the plan was to
begin trading my post of exchanges some
currency exchanges some male exchanges
as I said and also some rice exchanges
some food stuff and then gradually
broaden and develop a regular trip
anyway weather was real let me just go
on so John F Kennedy did not want that
in 63 because he wanted did not want to
do anything he wanted to win with a huge
plurality he envisioned Goldwater he saw
a chance to get 60% a we've got to
remember he won by 118 thousand votes
that's less than one vote per precinct
in America there's more precincts than
that and he won by you know the
narrowest margins in a hundred years and
so Kennedy wanted a big PerR allottee
didn't want to take a chance and so the
way you say it a way of looking at it is
ZM was offering Kennedy a solution that
was good and useful and he wanted but he
was offering it in the wrong time so he
had to die so he had to be overthrown
and that's pretty amazing I think we
don't elect presidents to do that and I
just think and I think the case is so
clear it's just another way of looking
something we haven't looked at
and he had to go because he wanted to do
something but in the wrong time period
pretty amazing it's very depressing not
good president long answer to a short
question
journalism question you're quoted on the
back of Paul burgers book the great
powerline cover up how the utilities and
governments are trying to hide the
cancer hazard posed by electromagnetic
fields then you're quoted as saying this
book should be required reading for
every parent in America especially those
with children in grade school P Berger
is as good a journalist as it comes well
since then the National Academy of
Science etc etc so did you make a
mistake of course but did I do something
for somebody I worked with at the new
yorker yes and dualism isn't it you do
it for absolute your buddy comes to you
absolu the book in your praises
absolutely i hope you noticed that
you've never seen one of my books I've
never asked for a contacted comet ever
never but I absolutely if somebody comes
to me and says you know the image of me
of course is the guy when you open the
door I jump and grab you by your throat
with my teeth but the fact of the matter
is I just did one the other day for
somebody if I don't do it I'm in real
trouble I have to do it for people and I
like Paul by the way he this was written
that book was written before the
international law no was it that late
thirty-five the one that I gave the
common ah you know 95 a little bit much
earlier sure
no anyway doesn't matter the bottom line
is I'll just I guess I should say I'm
that if you believe everything you read
on a jacket Tom yeah I've got a bridge I
got a bridge I want to sell you Pulitzer
Prize winner in Robert believe me again
no I can't say I'm not gonna do it again
because if a friend comes to me and it's
a first book and is trying to make a
living it's very tough this country a
billion dollars a year and scare people
to death and as you really got a hold
yourself back well usually I try and say
I don't try and get you know we can
argue this forever but you're right and
it's a bigger issue than just me I hope
you understand that it's something it's
very much in the business yeah anyway
yes ma'am
are you singling Kennedy out with these
different behaviors and I think about
the Gulf War and you know I think about
all the other women and iran-contra are
you really just singling it I'm writing
about him I'm asked to write about him
oh I'm she asked if I was singling out
Kennedy you know and she thinks about
the Gulf War about which we really don't
the Gulf Syndrome yeah and iran-contra
pick off Saddam Hussein you know I mean
we all know about that you know we don't
although she has to try and said
something about trying to pick off
Saddam Hussein the fact of the matter is
there's no question we were head hunting
for Saddam Hussein and violation of the
rules promulgated by Richard Helms and
the CI know actually was less injure in
the CIA I think the James Schlesinger
promulgated after the this stuff about
assassination and here we are and we're
not even making a big secret about it
sort of a teehee a collective teehee and
it's pretty awful that we target him
that I think that bomb that went down
the smoke pipe was aimed at him they
were doing headhunting remains are you
singling him out um I mean is it worse
is it generally across the board as bad
as he yeah you know well I you know I
hate that you know um god there's a
footbe answer to that as I'm writing a
book about the guy and I didn't did not
think I'd find what I found I did not
start to do that I did not think I'd
find that I told you the premise was was
the reason to think that something more
might have happened in the end to him
and in am i end up thinking I think this
guy Tom powers in The New Yorker New
York Times had such guts because he said
what I don't have the guts to say which
is that if I'm right if I'm right about
what I say about what Kennedy wanted to
do do these other foreign leaders there
was a rough justice in his death and an
end I ended up thinking that you know
they're gonna have to change some of
these goddamn highways and rename them
back off you know you know that's an
exaggeration but you know what I'm
saying I didn't think that's a total
hyperbole folks but the point I'm making
is that I'm not advocate the point I'm
making is that the point I didn't think
I'd find what I found what am I supposed
to do then you know somebody else is bad
I will tell you something I am looking
at the Gulf War not in terms of the Gulf
War Syndrome because I don't think
that's the way to go with it because
that's an epidemiology argument I'm
looking at it in terms of if I'm the
president
United States in the military fighting
force and I had a Gulf War I'll give you
I thought as I'm looking at it just
beginning to read into it I had a war
that ended up like this did which very
few combat deaths but maybe a couple
hundred thousand combat fatalities that
nobody wants to really deal with the
reason I don't want to talk about what
happened the reason why I the reason I
don't want to say how much I knew about
conditions there before I sent him there
because we knew a great deal about what
that battlefield was like a lot of
chemical weapons used there and a lot of
stuff we knew much more about and I I
dare say that they had every reason to
think that they made a good guess they
could protect the soldiers and they were
wrong and that's what they're afraid of
talking about because if they tell the
American people that we weren't able to
protect your boys when they went to the
Gulf War they can't get him to another
Gulf War and more importantly if you're
a military planner you can't get him to
Korea because Japan's downwind a Korea
the Japanese will go nuts if we start
this again
the Japanese worried about uranium
depletion weapons you know that we were
using we really we're using a weapons of
uranium depleted weapons which go
through armor and also then cause a
chemical cause radiate radioactive
damage I'm you know they they get into
the bones radio whatever the word is
they attack the bones were idiom and we
use those weapons so I would guess that
the story is more or less to do with
what they could anticipate medically but
the sort of geopolitical concern the
reason they can't say to the American
people well we thought we could protect
them we really knew we couldn't but we
sent them there anyway not sure and we
can't talk about it because we want to
be able to send them there again I don't
mean it's not diabolical it's much more
innocent really that's what happens yes
I would somebody else back there yes sir
I have not read your book well then
you're certainly qualified to talk about
it because that's I can tell you right
now that seems to be the only one with
the core status
what we just asked is I don't see what's
different what John Kennedy did and any
other president has done to it of course
the degree and my question is sort of
visit a problem with the the institution
of the presidency or is it the man I
mean you look at Roosevelt Roosevelt did
the same thing in many ways that Kennedy
did well the point I'm making is that
the characterization of my book that you
get often isn't isn't the one I wish so
having said that and but I think the one
thing you have to deal with Kennedy is I
think the the thing about Kenny that's
so striking is the difference between
the perception of what he was doing and
what he was doing we have a much greater
you know this is the original Teflon guy
you know I mean you know what would you
yeah but you're operating not with some
information you see that's the talk
about reading a book like no ordinary
time I felt Roosevelt I write I was not
part of that that era but when I talked
to my father who fought in the war and
World War two his impression of
Roosevelt is much the same as my
impression is or was of Kennedy and I
think that that people sort of in a time
especially during World War two they
look to Roosevelt much the same way he
had the same Teflon or we wouldn't get
him World War two well you know John FDR
Franklin Delano Roosevelt understood
something that Joseph Kennedy did not
and that is that there was a moral issue
at stake in stopping Nazi Germany the
Joe Kennedy never understood that never
understood that FDR did and then
whatever you say about FDR he understood
there was a much bit whatever and you're
absolutely right FDR at Hoover etc
etcetera and his personal life but but
the point I make about Kennedy and his
personal life that's what you're talking
about
is that is that it's it's but an
indicator of other things it's but it's
just a signpost it's an easy one for
people to absorb and understand and
certainly exciting for the public you
know people will read the book because
of that I'm not unaware of that but
basically there was you know FDR saw
something there you know there was
something very special in FDR
sorry for all of that and I don't see it
John F Kennedy I just don't see it and I
think the gap between the perception but
again you know let me go back there yes
sir
this is a question about journalistic
methods and it touches on the issue of
ethics hey you have a gold mine of for
Secret Service agents former Secret
Service agents or providing you with a
vast amount of information how do you
corroborate what they're telling you
well first of all it's not one it's not
- it's not three it's four and then for
those four you can only begin
exponentially to imagine how many people
told me a - go to hell or be talk to me
off the record not going near being
named I mean you know there was an awful
lot of Secrets III will tell you I
obviously talked to many more than four
plus there were other Secret Service
agents quoted if you in the book there's
a guy named Bobby oh you see Kay who's a
Secret Service agent who I quote only
about installing wiretaps oh well in you
know it's one of the things you know I
do for a living you know which is is you
take a person and you you you ask him
details and you then go and you know you
he tells you about trips that were made
and people were on it you find people
you find the trips you talk to people
and you know if you don't think I was
able to talk to some people who are not
in the Secret Service about some of this
stuff I was most notably some of the
woman involved obviously I didn't
without getting into who they are where
they are didn't write it but I obviously
went to some of the woman involved and
talked to them at the time about some of
these things they knew the names you
know some of the names are pretty
staggering I talked to and obviously
didn't write about so that's one way and
also in the community they were in so
you know the the bottom line is and also
don't forget the for them also not only
were named but they took the unusual
step of going on television and that's
you know the enemy talk about television
it's interesting I didn't know much that
much about television I been on
television but I never worked in an
operation before and in television
we had a guy named a guy that was a one
time a World War two hero that became a
mob lawyer was a state's attorney in
Maine Bob McDonald
who was really a shifty guy and he would
been a mob lawyer and he went on camera
after a year or two years of Rose we
talked he finally went on camera with
his story about arranging a meeting
between a judge and Joe Kennedy and
using the judge's chambers for a meeting
between Joe Kennedy and Sam Giancana and
the the story had some resonance some
some Providence even if you will because
because we knew from Tina Sinatra that
they had already begun a talk that they
already had some intermediaries going so
why not meet is sort of the next step
and if I'm interviewing for the New York
Times I can quote them all week
so-and-so alleged and then I quote as
negative stuff and I can do that for
network television I had to give the
lawyers and the editors at ABC they
senior executives I had to give them I
did about a week's worth of interviews
on this guy some of which a few a little
bit of it should trickle into the book
to demonstrate that there was a very
strong reason for believing him because
somebody on television is per se taking
the be telling the truth by the American
public
there's no caveat you can't use the word
alleged or claimed like we do in the
minutes our sign and when somebody we
write somebody claimed it's our it's a
tip-off that we may not even believe
ourselves it's yes it's you know so it's
interesting so how you do it
you just do it by digging and digging
and digging and I'm I'm I am here to
tell you that what they said happened
happened unfortunately I wish I wish I
could tell you otherwise yes sir way in
the back both missiles interview and
secondly did you read a book called the
search for JFK yes by Blair I read
Richard Bissell did an interview for the
question was did I read an interview by
Richard Bissell the former head of
operations in the sea I did the Bay of
Pigs did I read his book
did I read his interview in the Kennedy
Library and the second question was that
I read a search for JFK by the blare of
the blare of mr. mrs. Blair right clay
Blair and what was her name anyway yeah
I read it was it was the first book
written in the middle 70s the first book
beginning to debunked the Kennedys
raising a lot of questions about a lot
of things and a marvelous book that for
some reason although it got into the
mainstream wasn't a great bestseller and
the Bissell oral history I did read
Bissell gave an old history to the
Kennedy Library was fascinating because
of my Hmong other things
predicted so many other things he said
Richard Bissell was I hear there was and
now I sound like I'm talking Fantasma
Gary Gary there was a secret world in in
the United States and 52 and 54 and 56
and 58 the CIA were much more powerful
than you can imagine I write about I
allege in this book that it was very
possible the CIA had incredibly damaging
information on Richard Nixon in 1952
they knew he'd taken money from a
Romanian exile who would work with the
the Nazis and the Communists after the
fall of Romania and at the end of World
War two communists took control and they
and Beetle Smith the head of the CIA was
Eisenhower's aide the camp in World War
two and he refused to let the
information out on Browns he didn't
monitor on upset and the election for
eisenhower a lot of power and the agency
made a collective decision sometime in
the 5960 that they were going to support
John F Kennedy for president and they
did a lot of things I write about this
they did a lot of things to help John F
Kennedy become president and Bissell was
part of it Richard Bissell was part of a
group that won a candidate win and and I
argue in this book did quite a bit
basically betrayed what was going on
inside the Nixon camp as much as he
could the Kennedy and it's a long story
but it's a it's a good question because
he's getting into arcane stuff and it's
a it's a it's sort of a secret dirty
little lousy history that nobody wants
to talk about but the CIA did help elect
John F Kennedy they saw him as being
more in tune with their values than
Richard Nixon which is interesting
because of Richard Nixon Club here yes
certainly now the Cusack papers were
forged and you were duped in that how
does this affect the credibility to what
well tell me are they in the book uh you
know I've been here let me just say this
about those papers and and these are
these asked me about the famous Monroe
papers that in which he alleged that
Marilyn Monroe alleged that John F
Kennedy blackmailed her and there was an
exchange of documents in which which
Kennedy allegedly set up a trust fund
that I certainly did believe and that
turned out to be false and I I just say
because I have been I've been in in the
hot state before with stories you know
me lie the me lie massacre story nobody
believed and when they did every GI who
had three beers in the enlisted men's
club would call me up at home and tell
me what he was going to do to my private
parts this went on for a long time all
these crazy stuff and in the CIA when I
did the CI stuff I had AI Helms actually
among others
a three-month campaign mostly in the
Washington Post and elsewhere other
papers against my reporting in the New
York Times and so I've been criticized
wildly but this is the first time in
this case I was criticized for what I
didn't write and what I thought I
thought they were good I did a year's
work of work on him obviously I was
doing many other things and obviously if
you think about what I knew when I got
him in view of what I knew but from the
Secret Service they would I had a lot
more reason to believe it than the
average person could know and I couldn't
talk about it a little book came out we
were going to my lips were sealed and we
determined a year ago I shouldn't say a
year ago it was but we began looking at
it a year ago and about four months
afterwards in spring we pretty sure they
were we were in trouble with the papers
this is working with ABC we spent a
fortune on forensic it we ended up since
you can't they were handwritten there
were three to four or five hundred
handwritten documents in Kennedy's hand
and a lot of people think they still
some of those may be good they're so
witty they're so bright and you can't
dispel them because the all the tests
don't are inconclusive but there's some
type documents we eventually found where
type we believe on typewriters that were
available then and anyway so went public
with it I didn't feel like going to the
FBI about it that wasn't what I do I
couldn't write it because I was working
for ABC so we put it out in ABC in the
fall a US attorney be granted grand jury
and I for the life me I don't feel
anything but sort of proud I feel it
supports what I do the fact that I found
something it wasn't good it was
certainly sensational but I'll tell you
right now I am Peter Jennings both had
never if you'd asked us both we both got
a lot of criticism for it I certainly
more than Peter but he got some too
because he was the the front man for the
story the anchor for the story we never
anticipated anybody would we thought
everybody care about the forgery which
was quite brilliant rather than our
involvement the fact is as I said it's
not in the book and and I don't think it
does anything did a minute the day I
don't believe
documents and don't I jump jump on him
and get excited as a day I want to quit
journalism I got excited I thought they
were great I went after them they
weren't end of story I don't know what
else I could do yes yes ma'am
that's been written or said recently
about your book that you see is valid or
that is there any criticisms criticism
that I see is this your being a wife
question let me think about this is
there any crit do I is there any cousin
that drives me into a fetal position is
that what you're saying I just rephrase
the question is there any any criticism
that I write in the back of my hand and
then wash don't wash my hands talk you
said critics have said wildly is there
any one critic that you would agree with
oh let me tell you lecture let me tell
you the obvious criticism that's very
valid and that makes a lot of sense is
this is not a wounded picture of John F
Kennedy and the way I combat it as I say
and the best I can do
I say look folks the title of the book
is not a well-balanced rounded complete
compendium or history of john f
kennedy's presidency it's the dark side
that's what i say and i make little
jokes about maybe I should have put it
in plain wrapper paper you know but the
bottom line is if I I had had a
wonderful editor he's managing out of
the Atlantic Monthly who I worked with
for 15 years and I just insisted he had
it because he's not afraid to tell me to
go to hell and full of junk and he's a
great editor and the Corby Kummer in
Boston and he wrote me a note at some
point that's on my wall and it has three
things what's new what does this tell us
about Robert F Kennedy and John what
does this tell us about Robert F Kennedy
and Gen John F Kennedy and then three
what does it tell us about the two of
them their relationship to some question
like that I'm not quite sure I'm getting
it right and the problem I had is is I
decided just to stick to what's new
because so much has been written and so
that's a very narrow focus and I guess
in a perfect world I would have made the
book much big
and it would have been I just I can't
second-guess myself on it
I don't think and there's nothing
somebody asked me one interview asked me
what did you give up to the lawyers
you know the libel lawyer the chief
lawyer for little brown or for Time
Warner came naturally and we did it in a
day and a half I didn't lose one thing
you know there's a story in there let me
just say right quote a guy named Oscar
Wyatt Oscar Wilde's president of coastal
oil chairman of the board runs a large
oil company Oscar White's the guy you
might remember that flew into a Baghdad
he's this you know this irascible
irascible
oil magnate you know he runs his heart
large companies larger-than-life guy who
told me the following story one day yeah
I used to talk to him about Texas and
Bush and oil a lot because he was a big
oil he goes back to Joe Kennedy he was
working the oil field to Joe Kennedy in
Corpus Christi told me a story about
after the Bay of Pigs one had one thing
that happened at the Bay of Pigs is my
Tyrion the baby pigs is real simple you
know one of the great mysteries enduring
mysteries is why did Jack Kennedy not
stop the bombing and sort of back off
and I can speculate Jack Kennedy came
into the office bringing in the mob with
him and the CIA and in the book I say I
have the Secret Service logs of meetings
that aren't publicly available Richard
Bissell saw John F Kennedy 13 times off
the record between January 20 1961
inauguration day in April 15th now the
meeting sometimes lasted for many hours
I I have a hunch tonight if had
something to do with the Bay of Pigs I
just have a thought but you know
although John F Kennedy will tell you in
the historians will tell you that he
adopted he was saddled with the
Eisenhower program and the Eisenhower
didn't he just followed through the fact
his Kennedy stamp was all over it
and it was his program he made it much
bigger change the change the attack date
and one of the side things that Bissell
now talks about he talked about before
he died a couple of times only was very
fuzzy about it but I now have it from
other people firsthand in the book they
brought mafia and they bought Sam
Giancana and after all Sam Giancana the
killer from Chicago won the election for
him so he thought and he gave him
another assignment kill Castro before
the election why would Sam do it because
as long as Castro is there the mob
doesn't have gambling in Havana and the
gambling and the hotels and the
prostitution was all a great source of
revenue
people keep on saying to me oh how can
you possibly
correlate this enormous conundrum Bobby
continued to prosecute Oregon organized
crime and how could he do that and how
could they've cut a deal is sort of
contradicted not at all I'll tell you
why
as long as Jack Kennedy is in office he
wanted to kill Castro as long as he
wanted to kill Castro they were going to
get back maybe if Castro was killed the
new governments put in the mobs going to
get back to gambling the real money they
were making in the 50s gambling
prostitution it's all very real stuff
and so it's sort of a compelling story
it's a long way to go about about a
source Oscar Wyatt told me an amazing
story Kennedy then thought the mob would
kill Castro that was the assignment
before the invasion and as I said he
thought they could do everything they
failed and so you have to look I'm
argument I say in the book I can't tell
you the answer but you have to look at
Kennedy's subsequent retreat from from
the operation refusal to commit more air
support say I'm not going to help you
have to look at it in turn the prism of
knowing that an assassination is not
going to take place not only not only
Fidel but his brother che che guevara
and his brother role they all three were
supposed to be ripped off by the mob and
murdered and anyway
and I didn't write this because the guy
who told me this there's a wonderful CIA
guy named Jake estulin Jake worked
behind the lines in Burma in World War
two he was the most idealistic of the
CIA so the guy who really was in there
to stop communism saw it as a great
threat Jake's working in Cuba he's the
chief of staff for Bissell in Havana and
he told me he didn't remember it so I
didn't use this in the book he said that
two days before the invasion he got a
call from he thought it was Bobby
Kennedy but he wasn't sure Jake was
foggy but so I didn't use the story but
here's the story he tells he thought it
was Bobby certainly somebody from the
White House called up and said what
happens if we cancel it because once the
mob can hit once the mob doesn't kill
castro kennedy has to know his invasions
in real trouble
fourteen hundred men against cash
Castro's military which was all have
beefed up anyway anticipating some
invasion and Jake said well I said
Jake's very smart Jake said well I told
this guy from Washington he says well
they won't take a vana but there sure is
how it going to take Miami they're going
to come back and really be mad and you
had to get rid of that and so out of
this emerges can
shuts down the operation for pilots from
Alabama fly in by themselves and get
killed white out the for Alabama our
National Guard was training the Cubans
in Guatemala and Nicaragua rather and
they took off by themselves at out
orders that's the bomb and strafe they
were so angry at the Kennedy's refusal
to permit more bombing raids knowing it
was consigning the guys to death some
died most were captured and they were
shot down and killed and there was panic
in the white house that they had gone
and panic in the white house that one of
them would survive because if you
remember Gary Frances Powers the u2
pilot Fidel Castro pulled him out by his
ears at a May Day Parade and there was
panic that Castro would in a celebration
would bring out a couple of pilots and
wave him around blowing the cover
embarrassing Jack Kennedy so what
happened is Bissell went over one night
on the 18th or 19th and walked in and
Bobby Kennedy puts his finger in
Bissell's face and says those goddamn
pilots had better be dead it's an
amazing story and the pilot the families
of the pilots are told you're getting
nothing no pensions no anything and
they're very upset their husbands are
dead their wives and children all for
the men wives and children yell for did
and they're told no pension no anything
we can't do anything the government was
in a panic we're not going to admit
anything about you guys forget it and
one of them went to Oscar Wyatt one of
them was a relative of Oscar white or
knew somebody there was a connection
Oscar why I asked a wire to raise a ton
of money for the Johnson ticket Johnson
Kennedy ticket and Johnson Wyatt flies
into Washington and sees the boys
because he has the right to he raised
millions for them and he goes in and
hears the story he told me very much
off-the-record I walked in there and I
said to them you better give him the
money you better put him on pension and
they said hell no Jack and Bobby
he said Bobby did all the talking but he
knew Jack it was for Jack representing
Jack and he said I'm going to go to the
newspapers the Washington Post in New
York Times if you don't do it if you
don't give these people pension and then
Jack said Oscar will take care of and
they did they set up a lawyer I write
all about that and of course I had the
story he wouldn't go on the record and
when the lawyer came she said we can't
use it so I went to Oscar and Oscar said
are you out of your mind but he did it
he did it I faxed them some of the pages
around it the rest of
stuff and he said okay and not only that
he made it better he made it more
accurate
which most people do I found that if you
give people things to read in advance
newspaper men rarely do it they make it
better
people don't lie about it they don't
fudge it so they're I wouldn't change
any of that
I would do what I said I would do which
you know in a perfect world I would have
written a book twice as big and it would
have been much better I think in a long
run but it wouldn't have been you know
it would've been seventeen thousand
pages I once wrote one that long
$50 says the book seller yes ma'am
speculation on what it says about the
American public or an American press
that there's so much unwillingness to
believe in the things that you and some
other writers are writing about Kennedy
the question is yeah we've got to end in
a few minutes you're the boss on that
I'm Karl you want me to end it on this
question let me end it on this question
because so you can all go home why is
there so much unwillingness of the press
and others to - oh well yeah why would
you want to I really don't you I make
fun of that book by Kenny O'Donnell and
there is some point method to the making
fun um I don't know I'd forget me for a
second but just assume suppose some of
the things if a few of the things I
write just a few of them I write let's
just say that then so much of what the
journalists and the historians have told
us about that presidency is wrong and so
that's hard to contemplate you know we
didn't get into it but I recommend all
of you really think long and hard about
why we got into the Missile Crisis and
what happened I know people find it even
my a lot of my peers who like me and
like my work find that hard to accept
and I will tell you right now there's a
lot of wonderful new scholarship I'm
making this a I'm not even that bold or
daring and what I'm saying about Kennedy
in the Missile Crisis a lot of PhD
theses I read a lot of those are making
the same points on political scientists
beginning to turn around slowly but
surely and the political scientists have
been very skeptical of this presidency
for a long time but I also dare say if
you went out into the street public
opinion polls showed all the time among
the people he still gets a higher rating
and then Abe Lincoln
which is just that's an example one last
question one last question
alright said it alright follow okay any
I like the aggression more aggression
good thank you you was your very
personal theory about who killed both
brothers I mean I personally I haven't
read the book but have after listening
to the Peter Jennings Sean I mean it's
like there's an obvious answer to me but
I don't want to state the obvious I mean
the same killed both III think you have
to get back no I have I have nothing new
to add to it absolutely nothing new I
don't think organized crime killed him
because they why kill the goose that's
gonna lay the golden egg as long as he's
there they have a chance to kill in care
so Johnson cared so little about it
eventually just didn't he didn't have
the obsession and the same with this is
the question about who killed Kennedy's
by the way for c-span so I have nothing
new to buy I think it's a tar baby I
think the real answer is the real answer
you know it's funny that a I didn't
write a word of it but Marion
schlesinger arthur / turns his wife gave
a brilliant oral oral history to the
kennedy library they classified which of
course made me run like crazy to get it
and when you finally did get it she
finally gave it to me it was all about
the atmosphere of violence in that white
house it was what she as I say I didn't
write it because it wasn't relevant to
what I was doing she was methey really
she was writing about what she said you
and you couldn't put your fingers on it
but there was a sense of of out of
control and she then described all the
people who committed suicide who were
killed in violent deaths out of these
the White House there was an enormous it
was a keening place they were in a key
kneeing high-pitch and so III don't know
I don't have an answer I don't think
organized crime could have done it
I don't think Castro had any reason to
do it he was a you know he's - I just
think there's the evidence is slim I
think maybe he died is stupidly and
consequentially but you know in a funny
way it may be that his death wasn't as